Kevin does it look like that they're
going to be able to get to that 55
thousand units this year yeah and the
numbers that they had talked about was a
lot of that 55 thousand units was back
loaded to the second half of the year so
they talked about 60 40 split 1st half
1st the second half so really what's
going to wind up happening and the first
quarter number that they reported in
terms of deliveries of 10,000 units was
a record which means that wind up
posting a record for the second quarter
if they'll hit the number and then
probably subsequently records in the 3rd
Corps in the fourth quarter to be able
to get to that 55,000 unit goal for the
year but what about the model eggs
because we know that they are going to
be launching that this year but we've
heard very little about it so far so far
this year Kevin right and there's of the
55,000 units there's 5,000 Model X units
baked into that forecast with the
expectation that production or sales or
deliveries would start happening in the
third quarter my opinion is that another
delay in the in the Model X may have a
slight impact on the stock in the short
term but I don't think it's that much of
a motivator I think eventually you'll
get Model X and delay it and have it be
the right product at the right time I
think that will get absorbed right back
up and the company would be right back
on track and what about this whole
battery announcement last week right I
mean it was so heavily reported heavily
covered do you expect that we're going
to see a lot of questions around the
battery during the call today it's
possible there's battery questions I
think though when you look at Tesla the
way they report you know it's a lot more
near term I think you'll get a little
bit color on the second quarter
hopefully some quarter on the full year
but beyond that I'm not sure that's the
way investors and analysts are thinking
about the stock it's really about you
know are you going to hit this first
half of the year number based on the
numbers you've put out for the second
quarter and then that 55,000 unit full
year number is really what's important
the you know the other
this is while longer term and the
gigafactory and all that other stuff
plays into it I think in the near term
it's not as much of a factor okay and
and anything else that you think we
should be watching out for with Tesla
and the numbers yeah I mean I think what
we've seen in terms of what we call
alternative drivetrain vehicles with
gasoline prices especially in the u.s.
being reasonably low we've seen things
like hybrids and plug-in hybrids not
doing very well the EV segment actually
has done pretty well especially in April
and I think part of the reason there is
that the technology is much more
advanced than than those other
drivetrain solutions and what you're
getting is that segment the electric
vehicle segment is not just about a
dollar to dollar comparison to any other
class it's really stands on its own
saying this is the next technology and
this is where the future is so buyers
aren't just making a dollar to dollar
comparison all right Kevin thank you so
much for going through those numbers
those numbers that are coming out after
the bell Kevin Tynan a bloomberg
intelligent